foreign
John joins us in San Diego California
John welcome to the Ramsay show
hey thanks you guys for having me today
honor to speak with you and your
listeners thank you how can we help
yeah so just a question for you guys my
fiance and I are getting married uh in
August cool congrats and drafting up uh
thank you guys you know we've been
drafting up a kind of a plan to combine
our finances once we get married and
obviously we'll do our day-to-day
checking account but beyond that you
know I was curious what what you guys
teach I was looking for a video that
Dave was talking about this and couldn't
find one
um how many other bank accounts should
we have open or do you recommend that we
have open to just kind of manage our
financial goals and grow up the baby
steps I'm just curious to get your
thoughts first of all John you're a stud
the fact that you're trying to map out a
plan for this already I mean I feel like
this marriage is already off uh to a
good start John well you know dirt's
attract I think we both are into numbers
and maths and we're both very excited to
do this and you're both on board with
the Ramsay plan
all right John so I'm going to tell you
what I did in my marriage okay okay
great the first time same marriage what
I was gonna say clarify John clarify and
then after we were married for a while
I'll tell you what what happens now okay
when we first got married
let's be honest I was a genius and by
genius I mean I was an idiot and I had
an account for savings I went to One
bank then I went to another bank for our
checking account where our paychecks
were deposited I had another bank for
like a side hustle account I I ended up
with bank accounts everywhere and I
thought what I was doing was making
things very simple and cut and dry I
would always know where this was and
that was never what I made was a huge
mess a giant idiotic mess
and so now we have one account a one
Central account and in it we have sub
accounts there one might be a savings
account one as our emergency fund one is
a lagging fund because the way we get
paid here at Ramsey Solutions so I will
dump money into that one and hold it so
I can pay some my continue to pay my
house off and things like that but I
create we create sub accounts and then
if we want to have a sinking fund to
save up for a car we created another one
and dumped money to that one so it all
stays in the same place we can see it
with the same account it goes on the
same every dollar app we don't have to
deal with 50 different banks that's my
recommendation yeah that's a good word
there and I'll tell you what I do John I
keep our emergency fund in a separate
online high-yield savings account and
then we do all of our other banking with
a local brick and mortar uh here in town
and we have a checking account and then
we have our savings accounts and like
John said you can have multiple we have
one for syncing funds we have one for
vacation we have one for the car upgrade
fund and at doesn't complicate things
but what it does when it's in one
account it helps you separate what's for
what right because you have one giant
savings account you go well how much of
this for the car and how much of this
for emergencies and what's for vacations
and so you can make as many as accounts
as you want but like John did don't over
complicate it
if you have 15 accounts it may get a
little hairy so I was go I would say
have as few as possible while still
accomplishing your goals
yeah because you know with all the
Advent of online banking I mean there's
so many ways to check a million
different banking apps and she and I
have like several Credit Union accounts
that we've individually had open since
we're both in college obviously we'll
close those or add each other's names
soon but I like the idea of just
streamlining it so that it's all in one
place does this also go for like
obviously our Roth IRA is going to stay
independent well you know because it's
an individual retirement account
um do you guys recommend that when
couples get married if they have the
exact same financial advisor for both of
those accounts or you know she and I
obviously before we met at different
financial advisors for those so
um what do you guys recommend for those
kinds of accounts
see who does better you'll have a death
match and you see which one you pick I'm
just kidding yeah hey keep just let this
be as y'all start your marriage
let this let the word simple distill
every one of your decisions what's the
simplest way we can do this right now
the world is selling us complexity the
world is selling us you need to be doing
this if you're not doing that you should
be doing that and why why oh you're in
the world is telling us individualism
which is how dare you
communicate with somebody else about
their financial goals that's hers well
she's my wife I don't care that's her
goals your goals
simple simple simple
um I yeah I recommend having the same
financial planner that's so great I
don't want to get different advice that
my wife's getting and we're gonna we're
both working together towards the same
Financial goal and I want you in the
room at the same time talking to that
person right so that you both have the
same language and understanding versus
well my financial advisor told me to do
this they told you told me to do that so
I would keep it simple like John's
saying stick to that checking account a
savings account and if you want to keep
it separate because that makes me not
touch the Cookie Jar when it's over here
in this online account uh I like that
and you sometimes will get a higher
interest right now I'm at like one
percent which is amazing in the world of
a savings account crushing the game uh
but again it's not there to make you
money it's there to protect you